d'après l'INC les Français auraient
dépensé en 2020 4,2 milliards d'euros
pour s'approvisionner en produits
stupéfiant la première des drogues qui
est consommé dans notre pays c'est le
cannabis et si la consommation reste
globalement stable elle représente 80 %
de la consommation de l'ensemble des
drogues et concerne 5 millions de
consommateurs de 11 à 64 ans dont 1,2
million sont des usagers réguliers et
près de 850000 des usagers
quotidiens comme vous le savez le
cannabis est essentiellement enfin la
résine est essentiellement produite au
Maroc mais nous n'avons pas de données
chiffré que nous pouvons réellement
prendre en considération sur les
quantités qui sont produites et pour ce
qui concerne l'herbe de cannabis elle
est produite à plus grande échelle en
Espagne cette résine de cannabis est
essentiellement acheminé vers notre pays
par le par le vecteur
routier depuis le le territoire espagnol
nous avons aussi pour ce qui concerne le
cannabis un phénomène de culture locale
qui se développe en
2000 22 ce qu'il faut noter c'est que 56
% des pieds de cannabis qui ont été
saisis dans notre pille ont été en
outreem particulièrement en Polynésie et
en
Nouvelle-Calédonie la cocaïne est le
second produit stupéfiant le plus
consommé dans notre pays avec près de
600000 personnes qui en ont consommé au
cours de l'année 2022 autre fois c'était
plutôt un produit stupéfiant rare
servait à à certaines catégories
sociales et on voit que d'orénavant la
cocaïne c'est malheureusement
démocratisée avec une hausse de la
consommation qui est portée par cette
augmentation de la production mondiale
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure et qui la
rend forcément plus disponible sur le
marché français comme vous le savez les
zones de production sont localisées en
Amérique du Sud 2304 tonnes y ont été
produites en 2021 soit une augmentation
de de plus de 16 % par rapport à à
l'année précédent on voit que cette
dynamique est en plus une dynamique à
deux chiffres euh la cocaïne est
essentiellement acheminé vers l'Union
européenne par les ports d'Europe du
Nord notamment Rotterdam et enverse mais
les ports français sont aussi dorénavant
ciblés tant en mécropole que dans la
zone Antig guuyane en 2022 75,4 % des
saisis de cocaïne ont porté sur le
vecteur maritime et le port du Havre
totaliser 78 % des quantités saisies
dans dans les ports
français si on a donc euh
prioritairement cet acheminement de la
cocaïne par le vecteur commercial euh
nous avons par le fret maritime nous
avons toujours le support du trafic euh
par les navires de de plaisance à voil
avec les Antill françaises qui
constituent une zone de rebond
particulièrement stratégique dans le
cette route de la cocaïne vers la France
et enfin on a un autre vecteur qui
alimente euh le trafic de cocaïne danss
notre pays c'est celui qui est réalisé
par petite quantité qui qui emploie le
vecteur aérien et notamment celui au
départ de l' guuillan mais on y on y
reviendra peut-être au travers des
questions on a mis en place un
dispositif pour le contrer dès le départ